accompanied by his un ambassador
president biden arrives to launch an
unprecedented virtual covert 19 summit
he's joined by leaders from around the
world to discuss among other things the
vaccine gap between nations the global
shortage of oxygen
and the ways in which richer nations can
help the poor
the u.s has to date distributed 160
million doses of vaccine to a hundred
countries and more is to follow
the united states is buying another half
billion doses of pfizer to donate to low
and middle income countries around the
world
this is another half billion doses that
will all be shipped by this time next
year
and it brings our total commitment
to a donation of donated vaccines to
over 1.1 billion vaccines to be donated
put another way
for every one shot we've administered to
date in america we have now committed to
do three shots to the rest of the world
all on the call agree that fighting the
pandemic is a global rather than
national issue
amidst the pledges of help a reality
check by the south african president
of
around 66 billion vaccine doses
administered worldwide
only two percent
of these have been administered in
africa
a continent of more than 1.2 billion
people
this must be unjust
and it also is immoral
world leaders had pledged to vaccinate
at least 70 percent of the world's
population by next year
but as president ramaphosa also pointed
out it is now september and not even 10
percent of this target has been reached
this despite the apparent awareness that
nobody is safe unless everybody is
and still echoing the bleak message from
the un secretary general in his opening
address to the general assembly
the world is on a precipice
mike hannah al jazeera at the united
nations